something that I didn't really
appreciate till later and sometimes it's
um it was something I felt guilty about
sometimes because I didn't I didn't
really fit in sometimes I didn't fit in
when I lived in Korea because I wasn't
Korean Korean I would be I'm what they
call it a couple which is American born
Korean and I didn't fit in with the kids
I went to school with because I wasn't
you know I wasn't white and then I
didn't fit in with the Korean Americans
because I hang out I hung out with the
white kids so it it it created awkward
situations for me but I had to adjust it
was a real difficulty dealing with being
Korean and sometimes feeling like I wish
I was just create I wish I was just sort
of American I got it was a struggle that
I was saying I don't think if I ever
have kids they're gonna have have in the
future I just wish it was a little bit
easier but I think that difficulty made
things a little bit easier because I had
to really reflect in terms of how how my
life was going and why things were a
little bit more difficult and I want to
say I was paranoid about things but
sometimes I'd be like why why is this
more difficult for me or you know